- That would be like Walmart
opening up operations
in North Korea.
There are situations where being bad
is high advantageous.
When you put forth effort, you get reward.
You should be constantly revising
your conclusions, I think.
You have to very consciously
differentiate yourself
from where you think your
professional peer group is going.
He didn't want to work.
He had bad habits.
He had a bad attitude.
The systems that surround
doggie healthcare
and human healthcare are
profoundly different.
You need to have practiced,
to have apprenticed
for 10,000 hours before you get good.
If you are a doctor,
you have to understand
that you are in the relationship business.
We're just going to be doing
this for the entire game.
And you're going to be
exhausted at the end.
- He's a Canadian journalist,
best-selling author,
and speaker.
He's been a staff writer for
the New Yorker since 1996.
He's written five books,
all five of which have been
on the New York Times Best Seller list.
He's Malcolm Gladwell, and
here are his top ten rules
for success.
- It's not enough to have
a great idea and the focus
and the conscientiousness
to see it to fruition,
you must have the strength and
the resolve and the courage
to pursue that idea, even
when the rest of the world
thinks you're insane.
Time and time again, if
you look at the stories
of extraordinarily
important entrepreneurs,
there is almost always a moment
when they are the only ones
who believe in the value
of what they're doing.
I tell in my book the story of--
My book, David and Goliath--
the story of Ingvar Kamprad,
the guy who founds IKEA,
and the crucial moment
in the story of IKEA
is when he faces a boycott
from the other furniture
manufacturers in Sweden.
He's about to go out of
business, and in desperation,
he moves his operations
across the Baltic Sea
from Sweden to Poland and
sets up shop in Poland.
And that's what IKEA is.
IKEA is essentially furniture,
shipped flat, made in Poland.
That's the original
elevator pitch for IKEA.
What's interesting about that
is that he does it in 1961.
At the height of the Cold War,
at a time when East and West,
when Communist world and
free world are closer
to outright war than at
any other time in history,
a guy living in the West, Sweden,
crosses the pond to
Poland, the Iron Curtain,
and sets up shop.
You cannot imagine what a
controversial move that was.
That would be like
Walmart opening operations
in North Korea.
Literally, it's on that level
of kind of eyebrow-raising,
you've got to be kidding me,
who is this guy, kind of thing.
But he does it, and he
persists, and he turns his back
on all those critics.
Why? Because he is a
deeply disagreeable person.
Didn't need people to agree with him.
And that's how he's able to build IKEA
into this extraordinary,
runaway success story.
That's very hard to do.
As human beings, we are
hardwired to want the approval
of our peers.
There are situations where being bad
is highly advantageous.
And if you read--
I don't go into this in the book--
but if you've read Innovator's Dilemma,
it's what Innovator's
Dilemma is all about, right?
The disruptive outsider is
the one who is incapable
of meeting the marketplace needs
as the market is traditionally defined.
They can't do it, right?
So what do they do? They
try a completely new,
half-assed approach which in
the beginning doesn't work,
right, but that very
nature of trying something
completely outside the mainstream,
they end up upending the...
Were they any good, they would
never be forced to do that.
So it's the same kind of principle.
When you put forth effort, you get reward.
When you throw your heart and
mind and soul into something,
you get something back.
You know, in my book, I call
that notion, that belief,
that effort brings
reward, "meaningful work".
And when you look at the lives of people
who are really successful, what
you see over and over again
is this idea of meaningful work
is embedded in their consciousness.
You know, I tell the story
in the book of The Beatles.
Everybody knows about The Beatles.
They come here in 1964,
and the British Invasion.
The most interesting
thing about The Beatles
is what happened to them
before they came to America.
(coughs)
In 1959, when they were just kids,
they were invited to go
to Hamburg in Germany
to be the house band at a strip club.
And they went there, and they
stayed there for months on end
and seven days a week, they
played eight hour sets,
night after night in this strip club.
And over the course of that
extraordinary crucible,
that experience of playing,
they taught themselves
how to be a great band, right?
In fact, we think now that
by the time The Beatles
came to America, they had played together
as a live band 1200 times.
We could go to all of the clubs
on Friday night in San Francisco,
where all the promising
young bands are playing.
I submit to you that you
would not find a single band
that has played together
1200 times, right?
Just doesn't happen.
So what made The Beatles special?
What made them special
is that they were willing
to play together 1200 times,
willing to play eight hour sets
seven nights a week,
for months at a stretch.
And why were they willing?
Because they believed in the
notion of meaningful work.
They had an opportunity to
throw their heart and mind
into something, and get something back.
And that made all the
difference in the world.
When Dick Nisbett...
He makes a turn in his
career as a psychologist
where he goes from...
Remember, he thinks the
fundamental attribution error
in the beginning is fundamental,
and then he realizes,
actually, no, it's cultural.
And he puts out...
And it doesn't refute the
fundamental attribution error,
it deepens our understanding of it to say,
oh, actually, it has
roots in Western culture,
but you see a very different...
And actually, then he writes
that book about East/West,
which is incredibly fascinating.
So he gets two great books,
out of going back,
going over and correcting
his earlier position.
That to me is...
the model of how you ought to behave
in the intellectual world.
I think you should always double back,
and say, now wait a minute,
this is more complicated here,
we can kind of...
And "contradiction" is too
strong a word, but you should be
constantly revising your
conclusions, I think.
My strategy has always been, you can't...
you have to very consciously
differentiate yourself
from where you think your
professional peer group is going.
So to the extent that people...
To the extent that
people migrate to things
that are accessible online,
I feel I should migrate
to things that are inaccessible online.
So the value..
Or to the extent that people
stop reading books and read,
I feel I need to read more books.
So what I've been trying
to do is to kind of...
it's why I spend a lot of time
in actual, physical libraries
reading things in hard copy,
because there's a kind of
a serendipity that you get when you...
This is not in any way meant
as a criticism, by the way,
of search engines, for example,
which are incredibly useful,
but they also have limitations.
They reward a certain kind of serendipity,
and they punish another
kind of serendipity, right?
And if you really want to...
If you're interested in
serendipitous learning as I am--
Much of what I uncover is
uncovered serendipitiously--
you have to be a student of
all of the different mechanisms
of chance encounters with the unusual
and the insightful.
And so that means, not only
do I spend a lot of time
screwing around online on databases,
but I also very, very
consciously make sure
that I go to physical libraries
and walk through the stacks.
Even something as simple as
you're interested in one book,
and you go and you just
look at all of the books
that surround it, and the
connections are not always...
There are connections between them,
but it's a different kind of connection
than they would be connected online.
It's not a keyword connection, right?
It's a thematic connection, or it's a...
So there's all these sorts of...
You have to be a student
of these kinds of...
Of the different ways
in which ideas cluster.
And so, I've thought a lot
about that in recent years,
as a way of distinguishing
myself from other journalists.
I remain...
I'm uninterested in that topic.
- [Interviewer] Which one,
the relationship between gift
and practice?
- No, I'm uninterested in natural gifts.
I know they exist, and I know
there's such a thing as talent
- Right, right.
- And blah, blah, blah,
I just feel like, and so what, right?
Because there are people, I
mean, you're a basketball fan,
I always think of Derrick Coleman.
- Yes.
- I remember chatting with a
guy that worked for the 6ers,
and he said, you have to understand,
that Derrick Coleman was
the most gifted man ever
to set foot on a basketball court.
He said, you've heard
a million other names,
nobody was as good as Derrick.
And who has heard today, who thinks,
who puts Derrick Coleman
up there on the pantheon?
No one. He didn't want to work.
He had bad habits.
He had a bad attitude.
I mean, so what?
Give me somebody who want to
go to practice in the morning,
and who wants to try in games,
and I want to celebrate him.
- If someone were to follow
you from the inception to,
sort of picking a story
or identifying a study,
to the full book, what
happens along the way?
- Well, I don't really know.
I mean, sometimes I start...
There are about five or six times a year
I go to the NYU library
and I spend a couple days.
Just browsing is too mild a term.
But, wandering around, going
through millions of journals
in the most serendipitous way I can.
Just to kind of see what's out there,
and see if I can stumble on something.
- Without a clear goal or direction?
- No goal whatsoever. No goal whatsoever.
So there's that I do, as a regular basis,
and then...
I do a fair amount of speaking,
and I always try and have
conversations with people
well outside my world.
So today, I gave a talk this
morning in Philadelphia,
and I was talking to a guy.
One of the guys there runs
a medical devices company.
Very, very small one.
And so I started talking to him about it.
Because I've always had
this idea in my head
that it would be really,
really fun to write,
to compare the way dogs are treated
with the way humans are treated,
because they're not that dissimilar,
as problems for medical science.
But the systems that surround
doggie healthcare
and human healthcare are
profoundly different.
So, the same devices
are used in various hip implants,
well, not the same, but analogous devices,
only you do a complex
knee surgery on your dog,
it's $7,000,
and you do it on a human
being, it's a hundred.
Now, is human really 15 times more complex
than a dog, when it comes to...?
No, so there's something...
But I sort of had this vague thought
and when I met this guy,
so I started asking about this,
and he sort of started riffing
on it, gave me his card.
Now that's sort of how it
works, you know what I mean?
You take advantage of a little
thought you had in your head
and when you meet someone
by accident who happens
to have specialized knowledge,
you make sure you get his card.
So a group of really brilliant
psychologists in the field
of expertise research have
sat down to try and figure out
how long do you have to work at something
before you become really good.
And the answer seems to be,
it's an extraordinarily consistent answer
in an incredible number of fields,
and that is, you need to have
practiced, to have apprenticed
for 10,000 hours before you get good.
So, every great classical
composer, without exception,
composes for at least 10 years
before they write their master work.
- Mozart...
- Mozart is composing at 11,
but he's composing garbage at 11.
He doesn't produce something
great until he's 22 or 23.
Concerto number nine, I think. (mumbles)
If I asked you, how long did
it take you when you were
doing this job before
you felt comfortable,
and good at what you were doing.
- Yeah, 10 years at least
- 10 years.
And the same with me.
It's an incredibly consistent finding,
and it's really important
because it says that we are
far too impatient with people.
When we assess when someone
has got what it takes
to do a certain job, we always
want to make that assessment
after six months, or a
year, and that's ridiculous.
The kinds of jobs we have people do today
are sufficiently complex
that they require a long time
to reach mastery.
And what we should be doing
is setting up institutions and
structures that allow people
to spend the time and
effort to reach mastery,
not judging them prematurely.
If you are a doctor,
you have to understand
that you are in the relationship business.
If you are in a shipper,
you have to understand
that what you are interested
in is the supply chain
from A to B, not in managing
some transaction along the way.
If you're in the radio
business, you have to understand
that you are not selling a box,
you are selling an experience.
Those are the rules of the modern economy.
And those who grasp those
rules are the ones who thrive
and succeed, and are capable
of transforming the industries
that they're a apart of.
The choice you have as an underdog is,
if you're going to choose to fight,
and fight to win,
there are a series of
strategies available to you.
But they are all more costly
than the strategies available
to the favorite.
So I give the example
of a chapter about a...
a software mogul
in Silicon Valley, an Indian guy,
who coaches his 12-year-old
daughter's basketball team.
And they are without talent.
They are, by his own admission...
They don't even know how to play the game.
He takes them all the way to
the national championships.
He does it by...
He instructs them, they're going
to play the full-court press
every minute of every game,
and defend every inch of the court.
Now, that's actually a
very effective strategy,
particularly in age class basketball
if you're the underdog.
It's really your only chance of winning,
is to play a really aggressive defense.
It requires, however,
that everyone on your team
expend maximum effort
every minute of the game.
You cannot loaf for an instant.
You have to be in really good shape,
and you have to run yourself ragged,
and you cannot let up.
Most people will not play that way
because it's too difficult.
If I said to you, we're
not going to be doing
elegantly designed plays and
shooting gorgeous baskets
and passing the ball, we're
just going to be doing this
for the entire game, and
you're going to be exhausted
at the end, most kids would
say, that's not why I signed up.
So that's a classic
illustration that effort...
Effort is the route,
one of the routes
available to the underdog.
I can outwork you.
I may not be able to outspend
you, but I can outwork you.
Well, outworking is a tall order,
it's not easy to do.
As anyone who's worked in a startup knows,
it's one of the stressful parts of it.
But successful startups...
I've never seen any actual data on this...
But do we think the people
working for successful startups
work longer hours than people who work
for Fortune 500 companies?
My guess is yes.
- Thank you so much for watching.
I made this video because
Jim Jhang asked me to.
So if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me
to profile next, leave
it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know
which of Malcolm Gladwell's
top 10 rules meant the most to
you, had the biggest impact.
Leave it in the comments, and
I'll join in the discussion.
Thank you so much for watching.
Continue to believe,
and I'll see you soon.